Is that today?
Yeah, like between yesterday and today.
I think I just got badgered for you dude.
I think I killed that Muslim.
Are you recording the entire game?
Just getting b-roll.
For the brand?
For the brand.
I'm sure...
Dude, imagine...
I would love...
Bro, there's a Swedish Frith down here.
You're kidding.
I can't wait for that.
What?
I didn't want it.
Why?
Cause I'm like, you should've asked me bro.
I'm like, fucks up.
I think any kid in Africa's ever had a Swedish Frith.
Did you pour all the rest of your snowball?
No.
Damn, should I...
Should I eat it?
Yeah, I'm gonna eat it.
No, it's only right here.
Oh.
I would.
Hold on.
Oh.
Oh, him let's go.
He's awesome.
Go, go, go!
He's way outside.
I like the idea.
He was way outside bro.
Yeah, he was.
Who?
The person who kicked it?
Yeah.
The second...